Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
mirarlo en la Wikipedia ¿cómo se
llama el Presidente de China?
Efectivamente, el país más poblado del
mundo,
la segunda economía más grande del
planeta y casi nadie puede decirme el
nombre de su presidente. La república
Popular de China es un país oficialmente
comunista.
De hecho, su presidente, que se llama
Xi Jinping, es también el presidente
del Partido Comunista que es
prácticamente el único partido
político con representación oficial en
este país.
Sin embargo pese a ser comunista, China
es también el hogar de muchas de las
mayores fortunas del mundo, sus empresas
son cada vez más competitivas en el
mercado internacional. Y  no sólo eso,
China es también el principal destino de
las inversiones de las empresas
occidentales.
En otras palabras, China es al comunismo
lo mismo que Auronplay es al humor
inteligente. Pero esperad un momento
¿podríamos decir, entonces, que China es
un país capitalista? ¿Existe de verdad
libre mercado en este lugar? Hoy vamos
a contestar a esta pregunta, pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de perspectiva
histórica.
En 1927
China era una república supuestamente
gobernada por un partido liberal que
se llamaba el kuomintang
y digo supuestamente porque tenían en
aquel momento dos guerras a la vez: por
un lado estaban los japoneses invadiendo
buena parte del país y por el otro el
Partido Comunista Chino liderado por
este señor que vemos aquí que se
llamaba Mao Tse Tung, intentaba hacerse
con el poder. Después de la segunda
guerra mundial
los nipones se van para su casa con el
rabo entre las piernas y los comunistas
terminan haciéndose con el gobierno.
Así que, en 1949 Mao Tse-Tung se
convierte en el primer presidente de la
República Popular China y exilia a
todos los partidarios del Kuomintang a una
isla muy pequeñita que es lo que hoy
conocemos como Taiwán.
En sus primeros 10 años de mandato, Mao intentó industrializar el país con el dinero
que le llegaba de la Unión Soviética,
pero esto no era una tarea fácil dado
que China tiene más de 1.400 millones
de habitantes.
Además, tras la muerte de Stalin, las
relaciones entre China y la Unión
Soviética se enfriaron bastante, ya que
para Mao los sucesores de Stalin eran
unos tibios burgueses.
Así que, a finales de los años 50 nos
encontramos con que no hay dinero y por
eso Mao decidió sacar la madre de todas las
campañas políticas a la que llamó El
Gran Salto Adelante. En cuatro años
colectivizó todos las las propiedades
que había en China, incluyendo viviendas
y hasta los aperos de labranza de los
campesinos.
Las granjas pasaron a ser comunas
autogestionada con unas objetivos de
producción marcadas por el estado.
Concretamente el objetivo de Mao
consistía en quintuplicar la
producción agrícola de China en sólo
unos poquitos años. Y por supuesto quien
se opusiera a todas estas medidas o no
consiguiera llegar a los objetivos de
producción
corría el riesgo de que le metieran en
la cárcel o incluso le condenaran a
muerte tachándole de
contrarrevolucionario. Así que, los
campesinos chinos se vieron obligados a
duplicar o incluso triplicar sus
jornadas laborales y los oficiales que
se dedicaban a controlarles y asegurarse
de que cumplían con los objetivos de
producción mentían a sus superiores
para que no les pudieran tachar de
burgueses.
Pero no sólo eso, para poder
industrializar el país Mao necesitaba
acero y como ya no se los vendían de la
Unión Soviética y tampoco tenía
dinero para comprarlo en ningún otro
lugar, ordenó que todas las granjas
tuvieran su propio horno casero de
fundición.
De esta forma, los agricultores no sólo
tenían que labrar la tierra sino que
también tenían que buscar distintos
objetos de metal para poder fundirlos y
como en este caso también había unos
objetivos de producción impuestos desde
Pekín, en muchos casos tenían que
llegar a fundir sus propios aperos de
labranza para poder cumplir con las
metas.
- "¿Cuál fue el resultado?
Se estima que murieron entre 18 y 45
millones de personas.
Algunos por hambre y agotamiento y otros
directamente asesinados por el régimen.
Fijaros en las cifras, incluso tomando
los números más bajos
estamos hablando del equivalente de la
población de Chile".
Tras este fracaso
tan estrepitoso a Mao le salieron muchos
enemigos dentro de su propio partido,
gente que defendía una cierta apertura
al mercado internacional y una
interpretación un poquito más moderada
del comunismo.
El principal líder de este movimiento
fue este señor que veis aquí que se
llamaba  Deng Xaoping, autor de la
famosa frase
Tras la muerte de Mao, Deng Xiaoping y sus
partidarios consiguen hacerse con el
control del Partido Comunista Chino.
Estamos ya en el año 1979 y esto será
el principio de lo que podríamos llamar
eE nuevo gobierno chino se encuentra con
un país en la más absoluta miseria y
donde además es muy difícil hacer
cualquier reforma política, porque por
un lado
China tiene una población enorme y por
el otro medio Partido Comunista está en
contra de cualquier cambio.
Así es que, ¿qué hizo Deng Xiaoping? Pues
cambiar el sistema político a trocitos.
Y así es cómo surgió la idea de las
Zonas Económicas Especiales, que son
provincias en las que se aplican unas
leyes distintas a las que operan en el
resto del país.
De esta forma, China mantiene su sistema comunista en
todo el territorio menos en la provincia
de Shenzen donde se permite que se
instalen empresas privadas extranjeras y
además se ofrecen condiciones fiscales
muy favorables. Así es como llegan las
primeras empresas privadas atraídas por
los salarios bajos, y en poco tiempo la
ciudad de Shenzhen pasa de ser esto
a esto. El éxito de estas zonas especiales
fue arrollador y en pocos años se
crearon muchas más,
y no sólo eso, además, sirvieron como
modelo para que se vieran los beneficios
de abrir la economía china. Gracias a
estas islas de libre mercado fue mucho
más sencillo convencer a los gerifaltes
del Partido Comunista Chino de las
ventajas de modernizar el sistema.
Y por esto en el año 2007 ocurre
una cosa que podría sonar totalmente
contradictoria en un país que se dice
comunistas: China aprueba la ley que
protege la propiedad privada.
Por cierto, que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de RoadHouse,
un grupo de rock duro de San Sebastián,
en España, que nos ha mandado su música.
Si os gusta podéis encontrar más en
los links de la descripción.
Y os preguntaréis ¿significa esto que
los líderes del gobierno chino
quieren convertir su país en una
democracia occidental?
Lo cierto es que no. De hecho en los
años 80
fruto de todas estas reformas
económicas muchos estudiantes se
reunieron en la plaza de Tiananmen en
Pekín para exigir al gobierno que de
igual forma que había abierto a la
economía también podía abrirse en
otros aspectos como derechos civiles,
derechos políticos, etc.  Y la respuesta fue
una brutal represión por parte de Deng
Xiaoping.
Y es que, queridos amigos, este hombre
quería reformar el país pero solo un
poquito. Y ahora es cuando muchos pensaréis
que el sistema político chino sería un
sistema que combina el libre mercado con
una dictadura ¿verdad? Pues no y ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
Una de las claves del capitalismo de
libre mercado es que casi todo el peso
de la economía cae sobre los hombros de
las empresas privadas ¿verdad? Pues bien,
en China 12 de las empresas más grandes
son propiedad del gobierno y esto
incluye a los principales bancos del
país y a empresas de electrónica y
electrodomésticos como por ejemplo
Hisense, que fabrica televisiones y
teléfonos móviles.
De hecho, la economía china está tan
hiper-regulada que solamente se pueden
crear esas empresas que aprueba el
gobierno. Es decir, en cualquier país
capitalista
tú puedes montar cualquier tipo de
empresa siempre y cuando esté dentro de
la ley.
En china, el estado puede negarte un
permiso solamente porque no quiere que
hagas la competencia a una de sus
empresas estatales.
De hecho, antes de montar tu propio
negocio primero necesitas comprobar que
tu proyecto concuerda con el plan
quinquenal del gobierno chino, que lo
puedes consultar por internet y si os
interesa lo podéis encontrar en los
links de la descripción.
- "Puedes
consultar su plan quinquenal para
entender lo que quieren. Es algo así como
la lista de deseos que el gobierno chino
quiere conseguir. Las tres cosas
principales que buscan son pasar de ser
una economía basada en las
exportaciones a ser una basada en el
consumo; incrementar su eficiencia
medioambiental y acabar con la
contaminación".
Casi todas esas estadounidenses o europeas que
vemos que se establecen en China están
obligadas a asociarse o con una empresa
local o con el propio gobierno, es decir,
que se trata de un sistema económico
mixto que combina es cierto algunos
elementos del capitalismo, siempre y
cuando encajen con la estrategia a largo
plazo del Partido Comunista Chino,
partido comunista que no tiene ningún
problema en utilizar las herramientas
que ofrecen los mercados financieros.
Por ejemplo, el propio gobierno chino tiene su propio fondo de
inversiones y compran bonos de deuda de
estados extranjeros pero también a
acciones de empresas.
Por supuesto que no es el único país
que lo hace, y ahí tenemos el ejemplo
del fondo soberano del gobierno de
Noruega del que hablaremos próximamente.
Pero, es curioso que un país que se dice
comunista aplique este tipo de medidas
¿verdad?
¿Cómo podríamos llamar a este sistema
político? Algunos lo llaman capitalismo
de estado,
otros dicen que es una dictadura
tecnocrática o un sistema económico
mixto.
Lo cierto es que no es ni comunista, ni
tampoco capitalista. Y la pregunta es
¿creéis que algún día China llegará
tener un sistema de libre mercado?
Es más, ¿Creéis que algún día China llegará
a reconocer derechos políticos y sociales
a sus ciudadanos? Podeis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema,
encontraréis varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y no olvidéis suscribiros
al canal para seguir todas nuestras
actualizaciones.
Subimos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas, así que, no os lo perdáis.
Podéis suscribiros haciendo clic en
este botón.
Un saludo y nos veamos en el próximo
vídeo. Hasta pronto